nous venons d'organiser une réunion du
conseil atlantique nord pour discuter de
cette situation
la bulgarie la république tchèque
l'estonie la lituanie
la lettonie la pologne la roumanie la
slovaquie nous ont également demandé
d'avoir les consultations urgentes
dans le cadre de l'article iv
la situation est grave pour la sécurité
européenne
l' attaque injustifiée non-provoquées de
la russie sur l'ukraine mais des vies
innocentes camper rime avec des attaques
aériennes et aux missiles avec des
forces terrestres de tout direction qui
ciblent des infrastructures militaires
et des centres urbains majeurs
il s'agit
d'un acte délibéré de sang froid est
prévu depuis longtemps c'est une
invasion malgré cette litanie de
mensonges
et de désinformation du kremlin ces
intentions sont très claires pour nous
tous
les dirigeants de la russie porte la
pleine responsabilité
de leurs actions dangereuses et des vies
perdues les alliés de l'otan condamne l'
invasion de la russie de l'ukraine dans
les termes les plus forts possibles il
s'agit d'une violation
grave du droit international
un acte d'agression envers un pays
souverain et indépendant et pacifique et
une menace grave envers la sécurité
euratlantique
nous exhortons la russie à cesser
immédiatement toute action militaire à
retirer ses forces du territoire
ukrainien et à choisir la voie de la
diplomatie
nous soutenons pleinement la sur la
souveraineté et l'intégrité territoriale
de l'ukraine et le droit à l'autodéfense
de l'ukraine
la russie tente d'utiliser la force pour
réécrire l'histoire
et pour nier la voie libre et
indépendante ukrainienne
la tâche de l'otan est de défendre et de
protéger tous ses alliés nous ne pouvons
pas
permettre la moindre
incompréhension et une attaque sur l'un
des alliés sera considérée comme une
attaque sur tout les alliés il s'agit de
notre garantie collective de sécurité
aujourd'hui le conseil de l'atlantique
nord a décidé d'activer ces plans de
défense à la demande de notre commandant
militaire en chef général de vos noces
il s'agit d'une étape prudente et
défensives pour protéger
les nations alliées pendant cette crise
cela nous permettra de déployer les
capacités et les forces lui compris la
force de réponse de l'otan là où ce sera
nécessaire
en réponse
au déploiement massif militaire de la
russie nous avons tous renforcer une
défense collective sur terre en mer et
dans les airs ces dernières semaines les
alliés de l'amérique du nord de l'europe
ont déployé des milliers de troupes plus
pour soutenir l'alliance est davantage
de troupes sont prêtes à intervenir si
nécessaire nous avons des centaines
d'avions en alerte pour protéger notre
espace aérien et plus de 120 navires
alliés
dans nos différentes mers 120 bateaux à
lison dhalluin valaisan différentes mers
nous continuerons à faire tout ce qui
est nécessaire pour protéger l'alliance
de toute agression
jeu
j'organiserai sommet virtuel des
dirigeants de l'otan demain pour
discuter de la situation la russie fait
maintenant face à un coût et les
conséquences graves qui sont imposées
par la communauté internationale tout
entière la cible du kremlin est de
rétablir
ça se faire l' influence
détruire les règles mondiales qui ont
garanti notre sécurité depuis des
décennies et le subvertir les valeurs
qui comptent pour nous
voilà la nouvelle normalité de notre
sécurité la paix
ne peut pas être considérée comme
acquise la liberté la démocratie sont
contestés par des régimes autoritaires
la concurrence stratégique
revient sur le devant de la scène nous
devons y répondre avec résolution et
avec une unité renforcer l'amérique du
nord et l'europe ensemble main dans la
main dans le cadre de l'otan nous sommes
une alliance de tran démocratie unis
nous protégerons nos peuples et nos
valeurs la démocratie
vaincra toujours face à l'autocratie la
liberté vaincra toujours face à
l'oppression maintenant je peux répondre
à quelques questions
interfax ukraine
merci
monsieur le secrétaire général nous
savons tous que l'otan ne se battra pas
pour l'ukraine ne pensez vous pas qu'il
est temps
pour l'otan
de bâtir une coalition anti poutine
l'otan et solidaire à d'ukraine et les
alliés de l'otan imposent des sanctions
sévères sur le réussis pour leur
invasion
de l'ukraine les alliés de l'otan
coopération étroite avec l'union
européenne et tous les partenaires du
monde entier impose aujourd'hui et des
sanctions économiques sévères sur la
russie
pour démontrer
que nous passons des paroles aux actes
et que la russie perd un lourd tribut
pendant une longue période les alliés de
l'otan également fourni un appui
pratique
et technique militaire à l'ukraine pour
avoir une armée beaucoup mieux formés
aujourd'hui que ce qu'elle était en 2013
ou en 2014
je souhaiterais reconnaître le
professionnalisme et la bravoure des
hommes et des femmes de l'armée
ukrainienne qui résistent face à
l'invasion nous continuons à être
solidaire avec l'ukraine nous condamnons
l'invasion à grande échelle de l'équipe
de l'ukraine par la russie
et nos alliés sont événement unis pour
envoyer un message clair
nous n'accepterons jamais la violation
brutale du droit international
que nous voyons actuellement sous nos
yeux avec cette invasion de l'ukraine
par la russie
mais vous les informations qui montrent
que les alliés de l'otan font face à une
menace directe de la part de la russie
actuellement et l'otan
pense-t-elle à une intervention
militaire en ukraine merci
l'otan est la plus grande alliance de
l'histoire mais ne vous y trompez pas
nous défendrons et protégeront chaque
allié envers toute attaque sur chaque
centimètre de territoire de l'otan voilà
la raison pour laquelle nous avons accru
notre présence dans
la partie orientale de l'alliance avec
des milliers de troupes de navires ou
d'avions supplémentaires pour
prévenir toute attaque et toute attaque
sur un allié sera considérée comme une
attaque sur toute l' alliance non pas
pour provoquer un conflit mais pour
éviter un conflit notre défense est
prudente mais nécessaire puisque nous
voyons bien l'action agressive de la
russie envers l'ukraine
est dédié doivent donc
il ya très clairement montré très
clairement que la russie ne doit pas
agir de la sorte envers un allié de
l'otan
monsieur le secrétaire général
d'autres déclarations vous dites que
vous déployer davantage
de troupes
d'avions et de navires a le à l'est
est-ce que ce déploiement est le
résultat de l'invasion actuelle ou bien
dans cette déclaration ou faites vous
référence à ce qui s'est déjà passé ces
derniers jours
dites vous maintenant que le vj t es
faut être déployés sans nouvelles
approbations et dernière question
avez-vous des discussions prévues avec
ce putin ou des représentants russes
suite à la dernière action où est-ce que
vous suspendez toute discussion avec le
cette invasion n'est pas une surprise
nous
avons évoqué cette possibilité depuis
des mois
et malheureusement ce qui s'est passé
cette nuit ce matin
était prévu par nos services de
renseignement et de sécurité depuis un
moment que nous avons tenté d'éviter
cela en exhortant la russie à s'engager
dans des efforts diplomatiques en dix
ans la russie que leur action aurait des
conséquences graves en matière
économique
s'il décide et d'inde envers l'ukraine
mais clairement ce qui s'est passé ces
dernières heures montrent que la russie
malgré tous nos efforts diplomatiques
déployés et malgré notre message clair
de sanctions économiques a décidé une
nouvelle fois d'envahir d'ukraine
nous